my name is Dave Ellis I work on the
business development team at PDC and we
help recruiters set up in America and we
do compliance and payroll for
contractors so we have them manage their
contract book
so I mean the reason I started the
program was that I'd got some results
from personal branding and content I've
been putting out previously I really
just wanted to be a lot more strategic a
lot more thoughtful about what I was
putting out there and also get some
advice on you know which topics are
going to go down well
so it's been really cool because we've
actually just looked through some of the
data looking at some of some of my stats
for the last month I've been able to
double my engagement on post so comments
and likes as well as increasing the
overall engagement and then the best
thing for me is that I've had I think
eleven inbound opportunities just from
LinkedIn and or inbound leads I guess
from from LinkedIn so that's that's a
massive win for me
you know having a personal brand is
almost a necessity I think nowadays and
you need someone who's got expertise
like a Shem to help you like come
alongside you he's going to be super
supportive he'll give you ideas and put
strategy in place where you need it and
hopefully be there to be accountable to
you as well if you need that if you need
a bit of a push in the right direction
you